today's guest is a um
a barber
turned
criminal turned
entrepreneur and he was kind of turning
keeping all those plates turning at the
same time um he's a youtube personality
he's an entertainer
he's fascinating to me and i'm really
grateful to have him in here today to
learn more about him and to spend some
time
mr jeff whittick
[Music]
you my stories
[Applause]
what kind of fitness do you like to do
honestly
um i do it all i do a little bit
everything i'll just make something up
i'll [ __ ] run through this wall right
now this is a pretty sturdy wall
test it out yeah i bet it would take you
probably
70 reps
to blaster that wall
yeah i would give it one shot and i'd
give up after that if i didn't make it
through oh if you're not doing it for
fitness you're doing it for more
uh acclaim almost or like conquering
yeah training for life you never know
what's gonna come at you you know oh
dude definitely dude you never know if
anybody's going to show up and they're
just going to be
covered in drywall and you got to defeat
you know it could happen man you never
know when you got to fist fight a
contractor dog and he wants to pull out
all the stops that's right you got to be
prepared for drywall oh you never know
man and drywall's a gateway drug man
i've always said that
if somebody's doing drywall
it's not long till they're doing
pills usually or something some kind of
uppers you ever notice that over time i
mean i don't think i'd have a problem
with it
you know i'm i'm clean now the only day
i mess with sparkling water yeah
sparkling water and drywall
yeah there you go if i pop over this
liquid death crack it open man let's die
together
oh yeah feels good huh yeah cheers
brother
cheers man nice to meet you bro nice to
meet you too i've seen your work
um big fan i've seen your stand up i saw
that one time you did stand up on
mushrooms
oh yeah yeah yeah that was joey diaz
started all of that
because that was that's the thing about
joey diaz he's basically
he's almost like if they had construct
if they had a construction worker video
game yeah and you had to get to the end
and fight the big boss that's got all
the drugs all the drywall yeah he's all
the good plumbing all the everything you
know tremendous he's an interesting
character man he reminds me a lot of
guys from my hometown because i grew up
over there in new york new jersey area
so i'm used to guys like that coming to
the barber shop and just [ __ ] batshit
crazy
um some real legends i bet i bet you've
met a lot of
and i'm sitting here with jeff widdick
yeah and uh i just so our audience knows
and he is a youtube personality
entertainer
um
i would say kind of a artist kind of uh
i'm trying to think of how i would
how i see you i don't know man i kind of
feel like i'm in the same realm as you
but like i'm i feel like i'm the same
age as you two sometimes i just wake up
and i feel like i'm [ __ ]
not saying that you're that much older
than me yeah but you feel older i feel
older yeah i feel like i'm [ __ ] a
thousand years old sometimes yeah like
this week has just been one of those
weeks yeah
what is it like you feel like in your
spirit or do you feel like in your body
you mean or like in your
emotions like what do you feel like i've
lived like
like a thousand different lives yeah
yeah you know that's a great thing i
would say about you yes you seem like
you lived a thousand lives man you see
um
yeah there's like i feel like there's a
lot of different facets that that that
people could learn about you in uh
like a bar like obviously you barb
yeah i was a barber for years working in
a barber shop in new jersey where you're
in new york staten island so it's kind
of like a little new jersey of new york
yeah exactly yeah exactly yeah it's one
of the five boroughs but it gets left
out it's left behind and it kind of
looks like new jersey so um god dude
always wanted to be from new jersey man
oh yeah
yeah because it's kind of like new
orleans but in the northeast i think
yeah and people talk a little bit the
same sometimes like way yet kind of like
because you like people from new orleans
a lot of time their accent especially
women kind of thicker women will get
their accent will get mistaken for new
jersey just real lazy just lazy whether
we pronounce you ellis yeah you know way
yeah water darling yeah um and it just
seems there's always so there's so many
great movies kind of made about that
area where you get to see like
i think there's a lot of romanticizing
it feels like coming up in that area
like a lot of
um
[Music]
does it feel like that not for me no i
wanted to get the hell out of there the
second i was old enough to leave i left
at 18. i moved down to miami beach and
that's where the romanticizing started
for me but i was drunk all those years i
don't remember any of it oh you drank a
lot coming out you drink heavily yeah
i really like your stuff i i like how
you mix in the sobriety talk and you
talk about your own stuff you're very
vulnerable um
yeah because
i you know when i got into this game i
was like i'm just gonna [ __ ] around and
make funny videos yeah and i never
thought to myself like i would be
getting vulnerable
i talked to your producer and he said
that he watched the documentary so he'd
seen me cry already so it's odd for to
meet a man that's a stranger yeah and he
had already seen me cry so i'm still
getting used to stuff like that but
seeing you do it it's cool you know it
gives me hope like something to look
forward to in the future you know thanks
man well it's nice to say that i mean i
i mean i think
you seem like a really sincere guy um
was it all were you always that way or
is it are you finding now because it
seems like here's what it seems like to
me when i watch your stuff that you've
done kind of everything it seems like
you're this
this being
you're almost like this attack barber
that's what i felt like a little bit not
in a bad way have you seen the
barbershop shirt do you have a podcast
yes okay but but i saw
what did i see the
well i saw the one vlog too about this
like your history of your life that kind
of like sums up it's just like a little
bit of everything okay so really cute
seeing your parents
um
but you i'm just i was trying to piece
together okay who is this guy you know
what is his it seemed like you've done
everything or you wanted to do
everything
yeah i wake up some days i don't even
know i'm like what am i doing all this
for yeah now i'm doing so much i'm doing
two different shows i know i see you do
a lot of shows too but i'm sure you
probably go through it too you wake up
some days and you're just like [ __ ] what
am i what am i gonna talk about today oh
dude
yeah the past 100 episodes i feel like
yeah has really been like that like
sometimes i don't know and then i don't
know what people want to hear anymore
and i feel like i used to be kind of
connected to that like i was in the in
this pocket and then the pocket just
i don't know it got
either
the pocket disappeared or i disappeared
or something the connection wasn't there
sometimes yeah but you can't stop
because these people look at they look
to you for more than just you know some
laughs yeah you know you keep these
people going i'm sure you've got people
sober you know that are relying on you
now
yeah i think there's probably some
people that are definitely fired you
know they're excited you know mm-hmm
that you're in the first place
in are you sober are you because
well i'm mixing in all kinds of stuff so
right now i'm going uh right now i'm
taking i'm on my fourth step are you
just going to a meetings for fun no i've
got like 70 tryouts to try to sit i got
like 70 something days i'm going i'm
doing a fourth step right now okay so
that's where i'm at i i fell off let me
see a couple months ago
and
i tried ketamine therapy i tried that
okay to see uh just to help me with like
just like stuff from growing up or just
whatever to try it out
because i was off the wagon i was like
might as well try this ketamine therapy
while i'm out here you don't tell them
that naa right um no i'll tell like my
sponsors or whoever asks
but i try to always go to meetings
so i'm not like falling out of like the
practice of it i've never had a canned
flat water that's kind of
new to me i'm used to sparkling in the
can
really that's nice you ever see those
boxes of water
it's like a milk carton yeah it makes me
sad yeah
i know like it's like a funeral it's
like a coffin for water yeah it's nice
for the environment it's cool i i can
respect that but
just you feel like you taste like a
little linger in a milk you know like it
used to be used as a milk carton and now
they just put water in it yeah it seemed
a little repurposed slap a label on it
put will smith's son as the face of it
or something like that and then all of a
sudden you know yeah the liquid death i
could get behind this is a sparkling one
right you brought this one out for me
yeah i appreciate it i'm gonna crack
this one nick got you that one get that
no disrespect not put it right into your
veins dude this just got me this is what
got me off the booze right here really
i'll have 17 of these a day
like lacroix i've been drinking but [ __ ]
lacroix because i've been trying to get
sponsored by them and they won't do it
no no bite i hit them up they hit me
right back in the day liquid death yeah
oh they're ready dude they're right
they're gonna die with podcasting man
they're like we're gonna spend all of
our money on podcasting and go out
that's the way to do it like who's
watching tv are you gonna pay for
commercials
yeah i can't imagine that i mean the
money that's also that goes into
commercials and stuff like that is
pretty hilarious yeah you know do you
have it do you have cable
i don't i have hulu
so that is cable yeah that's i guess
yeah i don't even have time to watch
stuff at this point you're doing with
three podcasts a day
[ __ ] i wish i'm doing two podcasts a
week actually i don't wish
i'm okay with what i'm doing yeah
it's hard it's hard it's hard to
it's fine it's great man it's great
that's what i gotta remember all the
time is like this is a great job you
know it's fun to be able to think out
loud and let people be there sometimes
with you to hear you think you see a
therapist yeah i got a new woman i'm
starting with on friday you look like a
therapist dude is it the glasses you
want to take them off i could take them
off if that's let me see if you still
look like one
i mean put them back on [ __ ] i look
like a [ __ ] new york barber now
connor put the specs back on it's crazy
what one little [ __ ] detail can
change huh maybe a barber at a library
you know
come over here into periodicals and i
freaking it's your show would you rather
me like this i like them yeah yeah i
like them they look nice dude ma'am so
you went so you started off in new
jersey you were barbering you got into
drugs on the side it seemed like you
were just doing anything it was i mean
everybody got into drugs on the side
over in new jersey yeah and you guys did
wrestling i know everybody i know a guy
built a wrestling ring in his backyard i
didn't do enough wrestling but you
everybody loves it in new jersey all the
kids do like wwe wrestling yeah okay
people love that bon jovi did you do
your research like [ __ ] was that guy
nard war huh cause if you're going back
to my childhood yeah like i had
wrestlers but nobody knows that about me
i never shared that online oh i didn't
i'm not getting this from online i'm
getting this from thousands of people i
met from new jersey you guys like
wrestling bon jovi
y'all's moms
yeah
family
what else
that's all i know really meatball
spaghetti oh yeah all that kind of stuff
good feet
good food things you could pick up with
your hand and [ __ ] put in your mouth
oh yeah i eat [ __ ] everything with my
hands and yes
people love that yeah steaks too i just
eat a steak on my hands oh you got these
[ __ ] wrist forks dog you're right
but yeah i think those are things that i
just kind of generalize about new jersey
that are pretty safe listening to joey
diaz will give you a good idea about a
lot of stuff from new jersey in that
area um
new york but as new york you know so
much from watching movies and stuff you
get such an idea of new york i think i
just wonder like what
made you like what do you think was like
the fire inside of you that made you
like want to become or made you already
a personality that ended up on youtube
um
if you think back on it
i don't know i think it's just where
where life went you know like initially
i thought you know let's move out here
and make something in the entertainment
business i didn't know if i wanted to do
stand-up and stuff like that because i
had a little nerves to do stand-up and
that's why when i the first thing i saw
of yours was when you did stand up on
mushrooms and i was like
first of all when i do mushrooms i i
want everybody around me to be on
mushrooms too that's that's how i like
to because i don't want people on it on
a different wavelength not
not that it's [ __ ] like see how he
just came in here and i'm like what the
[ __ ] this guy doing right here that's
like somebody when you're on mushrooms
and somebody else yeah that would be an
enemy you know so yeah
you went up
on stage to do stand up when pretty much
they were all enemies until you get a
laugh out of them yeah you know so
that's [ __ ] ballsy i saw this guy
went up there he has a mullet he's
[ __ ] on mushrooms he went out there
and said it like i'm on mushrooms and
you stared death in the face and you
were just like [ __ ] this i'm gonna i'm
gonna [ __ ] kill this [ __ ] yeah that
was so i've been a fan man i've been
thanks bro you know i've been watching
you guys stuff
thanks man yeah it was
that was exciting does this bother you
that everybody has mullets now no i
think the part that bother like not
bothered me but like
i think it's awesome dude i think it's a
confidence piece
i feel like i have a big nose so it also
rounds out my face it gives me a more
heroic style yeah if you show up on a
horse or even on a [ __ ] bike like
this that's painted brown chicks are
like damn who the [ __ ] is that you know
a bike that's painted brown i feel like
if you come like
i feel like you just it gives you more
it gives me more bravado dude
sitting there with a cold ass neck like
some little [ __ ] twink that's all
cool what are you gonna do on a bus stop
yeah [ __ ] that feeling the sunrise on
your neck like some freaking busted out
twink dude
like i like i woke up today like this
whole week i've been in like a little
bit of a funk i haven't been feeling 100
but
having the mullet you wake up and you
look in the mirror and you're like i'm a
i'm a goddamn entertainer yeah you know
there's something going on here yeah and
i did this i did this cut because i was
going to skydiving school i was going to
learn to get inside oh yeah certified
skydiving and i was like i just need a
[ __ ] wild haircut just to jump out of
the plane and [ __ ] take the pictures
because you want the hair in the back
yeah a little extra parachute maybe help
with the velocity coming down yeah baby
and
after that i just rocked with it because
it just it put me in that mentality
every time i wake up i'm like all right
i'm not a regular guy
yeah i'm a skydiver i got a goddamn
mullet yeah i need to entertain yeah
whatever it takes yeah what am i gonna
do you know this is not for me anymore
this is for the people ah i like that do
you really start to feel like that over
time because i wonder like the pressures
and stuff that it that
that whole
and i don't want to put you in like a
youtube world because i kind of separate
what you can do
put you in that world too yeah you know
but you're but you're also a human but
that's where everything ends up at so
like
um i mean your youtube career is
probably launching the rest of your
careers and keeping you
or allowing you to make so much more
money you grow your fan base so
technically your main income is youtube
right now yeah yeah and cashing you out
they're not paying us that much
but they're they're a good separate but
i'm sure touring was initially like your
you know number one right priority no
top pay day and now it's all this other
stuff you're doing on youtube so you're
a youtuber too bro no offense no i don't
take it personal you know yeah call me
you yeah i guess i am theo von the
youtuber damn you know know it you went
in front of having that comedian title
to [ __ ] i'm going to change your
wikipedia
people on it theo [ __ ] youtuber my
friend rob knows how to change people's
wikipedias on the spot and make it be
that oh yeah yeah i got to call him up
but how does he work it
was a friend does or something and he
gave him some little cheat code damn
that's nice to have somebody at
wikipedia you just put whatever you want
up there i work at spacex you know like
i'm a [ __ ] investor in uber or
something you know yeah all types of
flexes on there you never need to buy a
watch or yeah you know just have your
wikipedia stacked yeah yeah
yeah dude that's a great call yeah
if you know somebody at wikipedia is
based you could say you went to all
these colleges yeah you have all this
cash
you got rob
you got rob over there yeah yeah i gotta
hit him up i'm gonna slap harvard on my
[ __ ] resume dude you know what let me
see what i take all my arrests off you
know never been arrested this guy was
squeaky clean he's got a [ __ ] perfect
record
let me see what i can do man but do you
feel like at a certain point like um
does does it kind of top out where you
guys are doing so many feats and trying
to do so much wild stuff was there a
point you realize i don't have that neck
like there's a level in me that i don't
have like a stevo or like i never had
that i never wanted to do any of that
[ __ ] i'm just a team player you know i
was like
i'm with this crew these are all my
friends and we all collaborate we work
together it's kind of like what you guys
got with like your whole comedian
podcasting crew that kind of blew up
over the past couple of years yeah we
had that where we just collaborate not
for money it's just you know we like
making videos together and we're able to
help each other out we all work together
well because we do it all the time
and you know we hit that pandemic where
nobody filmed for a while and my friend
wanted to make this big comeback video
and he suggested something and i was
like [ __ ] it yeah what's the hardest one
i'll take that you know just to be a
[ __ ] team player in there yeah and
then the mullet and then the [ __ ] you
know the the way you feel after jumping
out of a plane 25 times you just feel
like i'm a goddamn superhero yeah i came
in you're hot i was gonna run through
your wall yeah i had that but 25 times
oh yeah worse you know yeah so then
another little [ __ ] thing pops up and
it's like i'll [ __ ] do that what's
the worst that could happen i'm not
flying out of a plane you know yeah and
then yeah a year later your [ __ ] face
is smashed up into a podcast another guy
with a mullet
yeah yeah this is the downhill of it
this is what we're saying no this is
good i'm seeing it in a good way you're
doing a podcast with another another
youtuber
i appreciate you coming in man um uh
it's an honor
well thanks man that's nice you just say
that dude and i would love to have you
cut my hair sometime
um yeah i know i do mullets i do my own
so you do your own it's an easy cut yeah
you could probably do your own but i i
would love to get you on my show i i
would love to come on a and b i did my
own for years before i had hair hair
like this yeah and and i that i did well
this is harder to manage i think you got
no grays in there nothing huh i got some
man i dye them out a little bit oh do
you yeah right in here looks good thanks
man i appreciate it stress-free life
yeah kind of i'm just hiding the stress
free behind dye
are you oh yeah just on here on the side
yeah it gets a little dicey behind the
mask yeah sometimes i'll put a little in
here when you're not so if you're having
a week that you feel like kind of bad or
down or whatever do you ever notice
where it comes from because i mean
i could tell a little bit on your face
when you came in it was maybe a little
bit of just like not exhausting but that
was traffic and just new york
frustration in me still in you yeah that
doesn't go traffic never leaves huh no i
talked to my father and he's just like
god damn it he's cursing at the cars on
the street and it's just i don't know
why that bothers us so much you know
yeah
but yeah i know i came in a little it
was a little off you know no you're
great charming nice affable
but i just felt like oh he seems like
maybe yours your energy feel like well
then when you said also it's been like
kind of a funk week i think maybe the
pieces in your head and my head are like
oh maybe that's what i was thinking
about here's a question right here from
somebody
hey jeff i'm a huge fan
my name's mitch i'm from new zealand
i was just curious to know
what do you class as being successful
let me know gang gang
gang baby damn that's beautiful thank
you very much jeff from new zealand you
want to take that one or should i you
um
man success i think just maintaining a
level of happiness is is successful but
i was in the boxing gym earlier and i
was doing sit-ups at the end of my
workout and i looked up and there was
like you know they have quotes all over
these boxing gyms yeah it said i forget
the [ __ ] quote exactly but it was
like success is
consistent
effort
in
over a long period of time or something
like that that's how you get i guess
that's like getting results in like in
like a combat sport or something like
that but i guess that can still
translate over into
everyday life you know consistent effort
over time
yeah and
like we do that with multiple things
like the hardest part about podcasting
is probably staying consistent just
getting in here getting it done you know
like getting
doing your workouts just getting into
the gym is the hardest part
yeah that's a good point going to work
finish in the day without telling your
boss to go [ __ ] himself you know yeah
that's that's did you find the quote uh
that was john wooden's definition of
success uh that became pretty famous uh
success is peace of mind which is a
direct result of
self-satisfaction and knowing you made
the effort to become the best you were
capable of becoming i think that's i
think that might be the quote i just
butchered it so bad but i wasn't
planning on talking about it you know
i just noted it a lot because your thing
had three four words
but that's okay mm-hmm
um
yeah but do you feel like so i i
sometimes because sometimes when i
wonder about you i wonder well what is
there a level of achievement or what is
like a driving force because it's
something i wonder about myself too i
just wanted to get a blue check on
instagram right i was like i'll be good
with that once i get that you know maybe
that gold plaque on for like uh the
youtube when you get a million
subscribers like that would be like an
accomplishment that i'd be like okay i
made it right but it never goes away
it's never gonna go away i don't think
it ever will and you too you know where
do you think it comes from and what do
you think that is that thing
um because that's what's kind of
fascinating to me yeah it's odd huh like
what are we chasing you know like what
do you do you set a goal of money in
your bank account that is going to make
you happy and then what money can't be
it there's no way that money's it no
because then you just get all the money
and then you're like sitting around what
the [ __ ] do i do i guess i'll just get
high on drugs i'll just do [ __ ]
ketamine therapy like i i'm not saying
that's that's bad it might have worked
for you but like we just
always have like
i don't know i i need to stay busy in
order to not like
fall into the stresses of everyday life
yeah
you know so money is not it because if i
reach that
goal and then i don't have to work
anymore then
i don't know i don't see that as like
success or happiness i don't know i
think you got to stay pushing for life
like like that whole thing like do a
little bit of everything every day
consistently if it's working out if it's
podcasting you're working on other shows
or you have you do jujitsu right yeah so
you're building up in that you're just
bettering yourself in a bunch of
different things
each day
then if you have a shitty day at jiu
jitsu maybe you had a good podcast that
day you know
you got something productively
right there you go that's okay so that's
one thing that doing something that
makes you feel some sort of achievement
showing up like making my bed right when
i get up is always a good one for me
it's like okay i started i have one
thing done you know even if even if
that's the only thing i'll even get done
today everything else i might fuddle
through at least i started off with one
thing right yeah um
but sometimes it's interesting because
i'll look at
like a fan like this morning i went to
the smoothie shop
and there's a family out there and
there's like some they're singing a song
rain go away or something raining for a
minute and they're like it was like this
two a man or a husband or could have
been a lesbian couple but one of them
was real
one you know trying to be a man and then
they had two children they were having
like a sweet time and i was like oh
that's
you know whatever i'm standing here with
things bouncing in my head and
worrying about this that that's success
like i think sometimes you see it in
little just having a significant other
or having maybe i don't know it was like
some piece of happiness that i witnessed
for a minute these people didn't know
that i was looking at them
so i don't know sometimes like it's like
i don't know i'm just trying to look at
what the idea of success is you know
maybe we gotta have kids
you got a dog or anything i need i don't
i gotta say any responsibilities of
other lives
the stuffed animal's not alive but it's
like um
you know it's from a store i mean it's
good it's nice
i got a french bulldog he's oh you do
yeah he's 15 years old he's the oldest
french boy i looked it up yesterday he's
the oldest french bulldog in the world
and he's off the books i got him under
the table so i don't have any paperwork
for him of course i can't get him there
you go that's the most new yorker
i got him when he was four years old and
i got no papers for him so maybe i'd get
him like a plaque if he had if i had his
records i could get him that guinness
plaque and maybe that'd be like a
[ __ ] accomplishment for him where
he's like i made it i mean you know
maybe he feels that what we were
searching for but since he's since he's
got no papers he's [ __ ]
we can't even get him that plaquemines
will never get the documentation on
people don't know i got to get him a
wikipedia and then i'll get that [ __ ]
documentation he could have come over on
the uh maybe he came over on one of
those ships you know it's it's insane i
don't do any like special stuff i feed
him regular food from ralph's you know
just i don't do anything special where
would he work if you work you when you
look at him and you get to know his
personality my dog yeah
um who did you remind you of like a
night manager it kind of reminds me of
like uh
who's that guy that just fought the
heavyweight in ufc derrick lewis oh
really he throws those shots yeah like
the big overhand rights yeah he kind of
does that when he walks around when he
struts around okay and he's got that
build like that he's i think he would be
a ufc
top contender jesus bro
his best years are behind him now
because he's 15 but he was [ __ ]
an athlete when he was young was he yeah
now he's slowing down yeah yeah
we'll get him on h can you give dogs hgh
can you look that up it is human growth
hormone so ah d-d-g-h we would need a
dog growth hormone you need something
yeah i would think get get dog specific
i'm sure you could get him on a uh upper
at least to get
to get his wind intake stronger look up
what mark wahlberg's dogs look like or
something like probably the rock's dog
is probably jacked you know he's
probably got him on some of that stuff
dude i'd pump him with a little bit of
nitrous not every night but occasionally
uh
nitrous just something with it i think
if you give him more intake in the air
that's what's going to fuel a dog dog is
a small unit i mean it's basically a
[ __ ] little modem
if you did
can you do whippets is that are you
considered sober if you no right
because i don't think so
i don't think so i mean
here's the thing that's interesting
about sobriety man and i i meet some
people who will say that they're sober
they've been off of cocaine for
uh that's like joey diaz i mean he's
sober from cocaine you know i'm sober
from alcohol yeah right i say sober all
the time and i smoke weed if a [ __ ]
if somebody offered me [ __ ]
mushrooms or something i was in the
right mood
you know i would i
might do them but i say sober just
because the only thing i ever had a
problem with was alcohol really yeah i
never got into anything cocaine none of
that [ __ ] i never really liked it you
know but i grew up seeing my my parents
my dad
always no they didn't do christmas not
that i know of they might have been you
know but yeah i would always see my dad
with a beer every day around [ __ ]
like three o'clock you know
he'd pour it in a glass oh
you know romantic like that's his
happiness you know yeah he did not he
didn't have a problem with it but i
think i just have a much more addictive
personality so do you yeah for sure i go
[ __ ] i'll eat a whole bag of
sunflower seeds [ __ ]
you know at night i'll destroy a whole
you know box of candy this is heartless
huh
yeah it's bad that's that's my problem
that's my problem is candy that's my new
addiction and lacroix or [ __ ] liquid
deaths now i'm going to stop saying that
what are you doing with the candy what
kind of you doing nerd ropes i mean what
are you doing
it depends it depends if i'm smoking
weed if i'm smoking weed i'd be into all
that [ __ ] nerd ropes twizzlers wow
skittles even the sour ones you [ __ ]
wake up in the morning your mouth is all
torn up like what did i do last night we
used to do that thing we would put one
in each cheek a spree in each cheek and
go to sleep ah that sounds like torture
and just see if god wanted us to be
alive dude yeah because we didn't know
you know and my brother and i would do
it and he would [ __ ] take his out i
knew he would which basically meant at
that point
he's seeing if i'm gonna die you know
what i'm saying that's crazy in his head
yeah and he's gonna take his out because
i was the younger brother you know
so i'd sit there dude and just wake up
and just like
uh orange out of this
baby in the family um my bro uh i got
two younger sisters but we don't you
know youngest male they didn't really
count yeah youngest male okay
and then i got purple out of this side
dude just spree just coming to the side
bro yeah it looks like your deen
looked like a gay vampire that it
overdosed
i was not doing real well we got a
question that came in right here for you
jeff we got a lot of people really love
you man a lot of great questions i
posted a picture i tried to share it but
i posted the wrong picture i guess was
an edit of you
yeah i wanted to help you out with these
questions because i do stuff like this
with my patreon people and i have face
times i do one-on-one facetimes
and those are interesting some days when
i'm having a bad day i just talk to them
oh wow and that [ __ ] actually changes
my whole mood that's a good one you
should do stuff like that because you're
it is a lot of life experience too i
feel like you kind of have the same
thing going on like you've lived a bunch
of lives
yeah so we really got a lot in common
it's not just the hair you and i yeah
and the wikipedia page
fascination yeah
all right how's it going guys whoa hold
on
okay just wanted to be ready for this
that's a lot of voice in a purpose yeah
that's a lot of me
intentionally
i don't know i mean it's close to those
power lines this is a man you know i'm
saying i would be probably 200 feet from
those power lines to even make my video
this guy is definitely this guy could
probably grow apple this this guy
probably grown apples out of his throat
if he wants to my bad dude
this dude could spit an orange he's got
a [ __ ] apple tree growing out of his
stomach oh his adam's apple alone
probably i bet it's two pounds
hey how's it going guys
um
question for both theo and jeff
as we know both you have dabbled in the
dark guards before
so what what is your guys's each like
motivational factor that led you to uh
to change
all right that's my question love you
guys both
i'm sure the cast will be great game
game baby
hell yeah bro
baby what you got there jeffrey um
[ __ ] what was the question again
what's your motivation if you dabbled in
dark arts drugs alcohol sexual deviance
well i was like
i think i was around like 28 and i'm
like what the hell am i doing in my life
i'm kind of half-assing everything i'm
half-assing drug dealing i'm half-assed
in social media it's a kind of a weird
career to merge it's like if i was a
rapper and i sold crack before cool
that's normal but like if you're a
youtuber that [ __ ] sold drugs before
it's a little weird to get people to
understand
but right i could see it but i guess if
i just explain it like that like i'm
like 50 cent of the [ __ ] youtube game
you know right gang i should be dead but
i'm still here yeah i sold drugs before
i'm doing this [ __ ] now oh i like it but
um how i how i got sober how i [ __ ]
got sober of alcohol i was like
i need to take one of these things
serious and give it a hundred percent
because you can't have fast selling weed
uh you know you gotta collect money
people don't wanna [ __ ] send you
money if you're having like a clown on
the internet you know like who who is
this guy right about paying him he's
crying in his videos on youtube i'm not
[ __ ] paying that guy well i'm never
gonna get paid but yeah do you cry a lot
i mean i've definitely probably teared
up actually some of the seasonal i think
i've actually seen you cry too before
somebody sees deal
i had the wrong guy
that's not at all you not even no is he
relative maybe i mean
twin brother long-lost evil twin in
college dude minus the tats and a lot of
the uh
i have the same shirt
is this like a fan
this gentleman i believe lives in
indiana and we've communicated he's a
real person he's a real man yeah this is
a relationship so i just got the wrong
guy he had the wrong guy great guy i
heard he's a really nice guy
and he's jacking if we want i'm not
going to say he has hgh but if we want
hgh
he's the guy to call i bet we could
probably squeeze his understanding he
has the rocks tattoo
over there oh he might inspiration but
back to what i was saying that guy's
question
so i had to take it
serious you know you can't half-ass both
things
so i was like
waking up hungover and then you have to
get to filming and stuff like that and
you don't have your confidence that you
had at the night before with your five
[ __ ] friends and yet i was [ __ ]
killing it i was on fire because i had
the confidence of the booze but then it
just it
it levels out in the morning and you're
[ __ ] down and you're now it's time to
entertain
the masses you're talking 100 000
million who knows and yeah you have a
huge channel what's more important
[ __ ] steve and kyle and [ __ ]
whoever at the bar donny yeah
those [ __ ] don't even remember
because they were wasted too yeah and
they didn't have anything to do really
the next morning maybe or whatever but
they didn't have to do this the next
morning no no so yeah you need to be
confident in the next day and look now
that that [ __ ] fades because sometimes i
wake up not feeling confident still to
this day you know okay so then what's
the difference because this is
interesting for me too man even hearing
you talk about this because i can
totally relate to that like having the
confidence the night before if you've
been drinking or out having fun with
your buddies but then suddenly
feel you know it's just that thing is
missing in the morning and you're like
damn
yeah it's hard to just get it
yeah just go for a good run have maybe
have a black coffee go for a good run oh
a good run helps huh push yourself yeah
you know overcome something that's
mentally tough
and then i don't know maybe you just hit
the reset button but yeah after you stop
drinking for a while you lose that like
like damn this feels great waking up
[ __ ] sober you know but it like it
fades you gotta find new ways to
to you know get that feeling of like
just freshness in the morning you're
fresh and ready to go you wake up happy
maybe you stop jerking off or you know
yeah no sex
maybe lay off the candy at night
yeah but then but then you start to get
to the part where it's like what do you
have you do anything you know i know
it's i bought a vape last week and did
freaking
half a thing of damn peach pair nerds or
you know space whatever oh you got one
of the ones that you juice up yourself
yeah
i didn't even want to dude i went in
there and i didn't know what i was doing
and the guy in there was so the guy
looked like both of his parents were
weed like he was so [ __ ] high dude
like if his mom came in she would have
been in a cellophane bag right do you
even do you smoke cigarettes huh uh-uh
do you are you addicted to nicotine no
but i need i just needed something to
get in the flavors they're coming out
with you know i love like banana pudding
i love creme brulee sounds like you're
going down a it's a dark road bro so
next thing i'm in there dude i have like
nine different dessert vapes dude i'm
leaving out of there with i mean it was
like a cheesecake factory page yeah that
place ain't for you
that place ain't for you
um
but yeah having some kind of advice some
kind of thing i want having to reset
myself when i don't feel good that's the
toughest thing to do i feel like i feel
like for me when i'm not feeling good
and it probably has nothing to do with
anything external in the world
it's all internal how do i reset myself
to be able to be okay to others first of
all and then okay to myself and have a
productive day
and then i think that it that probably
is some type of a success if you can
figure out whatever that is for some
people maybe it is you have a family for
some people maybe it is you do something
for someone else you know yeah
go for a run sometimes doing a yoga or
something i can just get over that hump
of uncomfort sometimes it's just a hill
yeah you know um
but anyway i don't mean to go from there
i'll just love it maybe you don't want a
[ __ ]
thing a hundred thousand dollar hawaiian
vacation
you know
maybe that'll [ __ ] help you hit the
reset button yeah that can definitely
help man i've not been on that did we
talk did we talk about money and
happiness
we just said i mean i i've you know i
didn't have any money and then i've made
some money i don't have a ton of money
but i've made some money and i don't
know if it may i don't do not think it's
made me any happier yeah
eating liquid death he's not happy
enough yeah you gotta [ __ ] [ __ ]
step it up
here's somebody right here who's
obviously unhappy
hey hey it's michael mcneil
this is the happiest guy i've ever seen
in my life don't judge a book by its
cover huh
texas theo you're one of my favorite
comedians on the freaking planet
listen to you on the daily my question
yo this guy an apology man
what was the greatest lesson that you
learned being in prison and how does it
translate
into your business or your personal life
and theo you definitely look like
someone who's been to prison and came
out with a rough rough life so what's
your life lesson theo love you guys gang
gang gang gang
gang baby
that's a great question jeffrey since
you really have the prison experience
amongst us did you go to federal jail no
i was
yeah
um
i've been locked up several times but i
never did like i never did prison that's
after once you go over a year that's
prison so i've only been in jail but um
yeah life lessons that i've learned is
[ __ ] don't do stupid [ __ ] and go back
because it sucks it's not like there's
not people in there that are interesting
to talk to you know maybe i'd find a gem
like you and i'd hang out and we'd
[ __ ] hit it off you know yeah that's
that's rare that you get that because
it's not smart people that get arrested
and wow my bunkie was in there for
murder and when i asked him finally i
worked up the courage to ask him what he
was in there for he was like i shot at
somebody and i hit him in the head and
i'm like the [ __ ] you [ __ ] so you
[ __ ] shot a guy in the head unique
way to say it yeah
yeah
like i guess it was the guy's fault yeah
but yeah like yeah it was the guy's
fault
[ __ ] i guess it's like if you're doing
like gangster [ __ ] and you're just
shooting that [ __ ] like you're not
actually maybe he wasn't intending to
kill the guy right he was just trying to
scare him you know and he [ __ ] i
guess that's how he was trying to phrase
it or maybe that's how he lives it
himself and convinces himself
but um but how dumb have to be to shoot
aimlessly at least if you're smart
you're going to shoot where you want to
shoot
yeah so then it's like oh i'm going to
shoot him in the leg so he doesn't die
yeah and i still get to be a shooter
yeah you know whereas i'm just going to
shoot anywhere and see what happens you
can leave it up to the luck of the
bullets yeah that's insane maybe he
needs to i don't know i
he obviously made his specificity he
obviously wasn't the smartest guy which
is my point there's not much you can
learn in there you know it's very
political it doesn't really make much
sense you know that the inmates give
each each other a bunch of rules
and if you break them then you're
getting beat up by your own people and
was it scary
yeah it's
of course yeah but you know i'm sure you
get used to it over over time you know
were you angry at like the system were
you angry at yourself like at that point
yourself like i [ __ ] got arrested for
the dumbest [ __ ] it's never something
planned you know it's usually something
that you just slip up
you know yeah
it's not even like
i've done way worse [ __ ] that i haven't
gotten trouble for never like hurt
anybody and nothing violent but like
yeah so it's just guilt feel dumb
and then like the only thing you can
really do is
read like a bible or go to church they
have like a church on sunday oh really
yeah that god will find you in in jail
yeah you know and even the
like the the pastor priest or whatever
he's like telling you like you were put
here for a reason and like that'll
really like get you because you're like
i'm here i was here put here for a
reason maybe it is to find god yeah
that's why everybody leaves
lord it up oh yeah
and did you find where did you have some
a couple weeks where you were like in
the well you really got into the lord
club kind of
um
well i was raised i believe in god so
yeah i believe i believe in god too yeah
um i don't know what exact religion fits
me perfectly right now at this moment
because like the the catholic church did
all that stuff with the kids and stuff
like that i don't know i don't want to
get into stuff like that
but um yeah i believe in god
well humans falter so much trying to sh
because you're trying to
share the or you're trying to share the
message of something that's
it's a lot of pressure for anybody to
put
it's a lot of pressure to put on humans
to convey i feel like
the ability and the
the truth of what a god is i feel like
it doesn't seem like is it only human
like no matter the priest or the bishop
or whatever it's like that's a lot of
[ __ ] pressure that this dude's gonna
be the filter for that kind of [ __ ] yeah
yeah so you mask that you know you take
that kind of like that
i think a lot of those guys get a lot of
power hungry power happy
a lot of them are on jets now and stuff
dude wearing like oh have you seen
righteous gemstones on hbo i love that
show god i wanted to be on there that
that's actually the inspiration behind
the mullet kenny powers not in that show
yeah eastbound and down oh of course for
me to get the moment i was like [ __ ]
i'm jumping out of cleaning
northeast bound and up dude
yeah what do you mean jeff whitaker
north oh yeah yeah just like i was just
saying where you're from but um
i'm just yeah i want to be on the same
wavelength as you feel your brain you
got an interesting brain you're one of a
kind you got one you have a specific
style in your comedy that
i don't know who you are even close to
like compare you to you know
it's thanks man you know what i'm saying
right well i think you have a real
ability man that people love you for
some reason
yeah i don't know what it is did you
switch out producers because i i watched
a podcast episode i thought you had like
a small asian boy or was helping you in
nashville we have a fella oh yeah yeah
riley he's uh yeah he's still around he
does a lot of he does a lot of stuff
with the church he's with the church and
so it's hard to get a hold of him you
know he's doing he does outings boy
scouts he's in him oh yeah he's a man
he's still doing boy scouts so he's
he's 20 i think 20. i got a bunch of 20
year olds working for me setting up my
[ __ ] and they all they're all [ __ ]
idiots they have no credentials to be
doing any of this stuff but i love them
they make me happy you know i don't care
if you know you don't you you have all
this [ __ ] gear and stuff if you just
make me happy you just got to be in a
good mood to film sometimes you know
like this guy when i first came in here
and saw him he got me right out of it
you know yeah he loves you nick's a big
fan of yours
big fan of yours too thank you for
setting this up yeah nixon nick's done a
great job man he's helped this podcast
so much over the years but yeah having a
[ __ ] bunch of 20 year olds you know
that energy is fun because they're just
like they're it's so funny
they say no calf all the time like stop
saying that [ __ ] [ __ ] around here
yeah they're all wearing chains and like
getting to baby tattoos yeah yeah yeah
they talking about little oozy vert and
stuff like that
they keep me
young but also you know now i might what
if there's a draft we might lose them
all you know i'm having no team that'll
rope up all my 20 year old guys i can't
imagine if there's a draft dude we're
gonna be basically gonna be a bunch of
people
hiding with vapes on the front line
exactly
damn we're [ __ ] now
they're all going to be doing those like
looted [ __ ] uh stick talks and [ __ ]
they're gonna be yeah
yeah it's a viral tick tock war in
afghanistan those new ones you haven't
seen the ones that got everyone hanging
on the plane uh i've seen some of that
yesterday yes
but i haven't seen that that [ __ ] isn't
doesn't drive you [ __ ] nuts like
we're over here talking about it's tough
to get in here do a podcast once a week
and these guys are hanging on the sides
of planes because their lives are so
[ __ ] right but it's like what it
it does but then it's like if it weren't
for social media and stuff
i wouldn't know about that which is or
some of it i wouldn't see and it's okay
it doesn't mean that i don't want to
know about it but it's it's interesting
the amount of stuff we know about now i
don't know if we can handle it as humans
i don't know if we're built to handle
all of this stuff it's like somebody you
know because then what can you or i do
we could donate we could join the
service if we get drafted yeah we could
help an afghan friend or something i
think joining the service is the only
like actual thing that we could do
really like posting something on your
social media yeah you're bringing
awareness to it and there's enough
awareness bro there's so much awareness
we don't need any more awareness i know
people is dumb i know people are
starving
i know people are
doing rapes i know people are
unhappy i know people are mentally
unwell i'm live inside of one i know
people that shot people in the head yeah
there you go yeah yeah
even though it was the guy who moved his
head into the bullets
yeah [ __ ] but the awareness too much
yeah we don't need any more awareness
i'm so aware bro that it's like but it's
money for people because it's clicks you
know we need clicks we need to [ __ ]
get some clicks on this you pro backs or
anti huh
let's talk taliban let's talk [ __ ]
building seven
real [ __ ] let's get some let's go
if you don't believe in time building
seven
oh yeah if you don't believe in power
seven i don't even know if you're inside
it was inside i mean look there's a guy
running out with an ij tattoo on his
wrist you can see it bro they found it
in a video my mom was in she was in the
tower she was in the first hour i know
she was the secretary
yeah but she doesn't think it's an
inside job i'm always trying to get her
and like having the kids and my 20 year
old employees they'll call her and
they'll be like we we believe it was
aliens that flew the planes in and my
mom's like what are you what are these
guys smoking that are working for you
[Laughter]
aliens flew the [ __ ] planes into the
towers it's like atmosphere
yeah yeah she thinks everything i do is
[ __ ] like i don't know she watches
all my stuff oh of course man my mom
does too
oh yeah yeah i think it makes them feel
like closer to you or i don't know i
think i'm sure my mom has gotten to know
me way better through my podcast than
100 percent human i never talked about
drug use in front of my parents any
vulnerable [ __ ] nothing even that stuff
i said about i might get yelled at
because saying i'm not catholic
technically anymore i might get whacked
when i you know my mom might be waiting
in the parking lot
you know
they're driving across country right now
they got an rv they're retired so
they're coming to see you yeah yeah
they're driving across the country
they're stopping at some campgrounds and
stuff like that do they stay at like uh
koa and stuff like that
um i don't know what that is
it's like a it's a just a sir it's like
a safe enough like a trailer park term
yeah koa's like
they got clean bathrooms sometimes they
have like a uh
little group center in the middle oh
there we go yeah i think they're doing
stuff like this i sent i was out in
malibu shooting some stuff and i found a
campsite that was on the water and i
sent the like a video to my dad and he
was like
as expensive [ __ ] like i'm gonna find
like a piece of [ __ ] lot for [ __ ] 20
bucks
yeah he was pissed off he just gets
pissed i'm just sending him to send him
a video you know yeah look at this nice
campground
he gets mad
do you think getting mad is like a new
yorker it's just it's a natural
first-rate it's like saying hello a
little bit yeah it wouldn't be normal if
if he was like oh that's really nice i
would love to visit i'd be like what the
[ __ ] dad
would you wouldn't you [ __ ] turn gay
or something yeah what's going on bob
you get it or what you got something to
tell me a mom huh let me get grandma on
the line oh [ __ ] grandma's dead we'll
get a ouija board she needs to hear this
um
what about this right here what do you
think about this man this just happened
look at that body on the pitcher pitch
baseball players physiques are so funny
to me you know because their athletes
are pro athletes but they don't have to
be
like ripped or like ufc fighters you
have to use every pound on your body
that's a good muscle you know these guys
don't give a [ __ ] they're out doing blow
and [ __ ] eating fried chicken
and then they get up the next day and
just throw a 99 mile an hour fastball
that's really all you got to worry about
just this thing making sure this is good
that might be the one you might be
talking about the white sox specifically
but there are a lot of good i think
there's a lot of i think some guys every
now and then you get that still kind of
thicky thick guy out there
now what are you doing now that guy's
got some beef on him oh yeah he does
you're right you got a belly be very
better careful
well folks i think i missed the whole
uh point of this video so he said
something racist to him yeah that was
actually that this is this was actually
him he did he did a little asian accent
now what do you do
this is the see like
we can't change this you know we have no
power over this there's nothing we can
do about this right yeah we can't change
this at all we're spreading awareness
right now
did you see that video of the girls
getting her hand bit by the alligator i
haven't
can you look that up yeah do we want to
play this one yeah let's just get
through this what do you think about
this man did you hear the guy he said
he's about to he's about to do the
accent and then they cut to after his
suspension when he returned and he
apologizes to the shohio time
now what do you do with shoei ohtani
be very better careful
oh the announcer did it yeah you didn't
even notice it the first time i didn't
even notice it no dinger man damn you
gotta know your [ __ ] place he got
suspended too for it and here's his
apology well folks uh shohei watani has
come to the plate and uh it's been
brought to my attention and i sincerely
apologize if i offended anybody
especially anybody in the asian
community
for what i said about pitching and being
careful you just started a world war bro
that's america's favorite past time
we're putting chinese racism in there
that's [ __ ] terrible i thought it was
the players going at it back and forth
and i'm like this is just [ __ ] talk at
first i didn't i wasn't paying attention
really i was thinking about that
alligator video with the girl and her
hand getting caught in there
yeah
but yeah no that's terrible yeah do you
think you think it's terrible that the
guy did it
you got to know your spot you're an
announcer you know like i'm scared to do
live podcasts because i might slip up
i'm just i don't give a [ __ ] about what
i say sometimes and there's like no
filters so
i won't do live sometimes but this guy
knows you're live and
you don't have a crew of 20 year olds
that are going to edit this after you
know be there i got i got the story
wrong that was the same game his next
step at and today he has been suspended
indefinitely jack morris the announcer
even after his apology on air
i feel like you let the man have an
apology maybe you maybe you suspend him
a game but i don't think it goes any
further than that it didn't i feel like
you can blatantly hear from his
intention that it didn't he didn't mean
anything
maybe somebody he who he knows who's
japanese has always said that in his
life or something sometimes you get a
thing stuck in your head that come out
yeah i don't know
like baseball commentary
it's like
maybe that's not for you maybe you
wanted to be a comedian if you're trying
to make jokes and get laughs maybe you
should be trying that out of the laugh
factory you know not on a [ __ ]
baseball game
yeah but do you think what do you think
do you think his intention that's why i
wonder what was his intention
trying to get laughs i think guys also
maybe 70 years old do we know how old he
is
just out of touch
yeah you know probably he needs some
[ __ ] whoa kids around him to teach
him you can't be doing that [ __ ] this is
20 21. he needs some kids to teach him
that aliens
are what those kids tell your parents
building seven yeah
building seven so you need to watch your
[ __ ] japanese accent yeah okay what
are you doing man yeah we got bigger
fists to fry
in like our country here dude it's crazy
we can get china's flu but we can't do
an accent of them for two seconds
baseball game they don't [ __ ] around
they don't have youtube instagram none
of the [ __ ] we have they ban everything
except they do have tick tock though man
oh yeah i have a chinese a friend of
mine is a chinese masseuse this lady
yuli
and she uh
shows me your tick tocks but how come we
don't i don't see chinese tick tocks i
don't think they let us see theirs
really so she has one that she's able to
use i think because i don't know she is
chinese maybe her phone program is from
china
yeah
yeah i think she'd be paying roaming
pull up the crocodile video if you could
find it yes this is interesting and and
not to take away from this this is a
serious issue but this crocodile video
it's not you're gonna appreciate because
this this girl they're both different
crocodiles one of them is freaking one
of the crocodiles is uh
big brother and the other crocodile is
an actual crocodile
okay look at the way this girl handled
this situation here i could
see know my my uh my sister mm-hmm doing
something like this because she works
with animals she's a
a racehorse owner she owns a resources
she lives out in kentucky for equestrian
uh no racehorses
like thoroughbreds so uh
and she does jiu jitsu so watch how this
girl handles this because this animal is
goes to [ __ ] tear her arm
[Music]
look at that
this is not the video i saw on instagram
it's got
it is it is the same video but i don't
know why they needed to break down the
backstory on the crocodile's life
you know that's how they do it now dude
where it's who it's a whole iceland
documentary yeah this thing was at nobu
before it showed up
yeah that's the one we want warning
reminds me of my 15 year old french
bulldog delete
so look she goes in there now with it
the thing's locked in look at the roll
she rolls with it to save her arm and
then she body triangles them look at
that body triangle she must be a
she must be at least a purple belt
right
have you learned that move yet
yeah i think i have i'm only once drive
wipeout
this is what you got to do to get the
black belt you got to get in the crock
tank
oh i left last session i couldn't even
find parking that's why so that's where
i'm at right now oh yeah
it's do you go through phases of stuff
like yeah i go to phases where literally
i'll get my ribs cracked and i can't go
for two and a half weeks that's what my
biggest problem is oh so it's a body you
give it out yeah it really is and that's
almost sad but part of that's depressing
too yeah but take me through some of
this jeff this is interesting because
this i feel like is the difference
between you and me like i would like to
watch that shohei ohtani thing and talk
about the race and you're like no
you want to get r you want to see some
races an alligator she's using bjj
brazilian art form of martial arts and
once we discuss it i agree with you way
better dude yeah
i i love the way that i don't want to
come on here and start you know
switching up topics and stuff if you had
plans to talk about that we go back to
the baseball stuff no you know way more
than i do about how to do this kind of
thing man i think this is good and i
think that you
i love the way you took us through it
dude i love the role i don't even know
if i would have noticed the thing roll
like that
yeah i i don't know uh maybe you know i
just
and she rolled that's total bjj right
there yeah yeah and then they wrapped it
up the body triangle and while her
hand's locked in teeth there's teeth
going through her wrist right now she
stays in and looks there's to keep your
composure no nonsense keith peterson
jumping in there at the end look at that
yeah this guy was scared to get in there
he's like first
i should have left he called in
who is he yeah he's the guy
that's a good bro what a freaking cop
out yelling we got trouble in here when
you're the dude who's supposed to be
yeah
yeah thank god that girl is trained you
know yeah that's crazy she was she's
mentally tough too yeah
yeah my sister does bjj she's a purple
belt so i that reminds me of her kind of
are you guys pretty close
yeah i mean i'll beat the [ __ ] out of
her now yeah that's like she's older
than me so she used to kick my ass when
i was younger but you know
i wouldn't i wouldn't want to you know
roll with her i wouldn't
you know
how how mcgregor starts his fights out
he puts the push kick test him just get
away karen i don't wanna go right now
we're 30s we're in our 30s
dude his first my sister's get away
and i'm jeff my mom
predicted memes
while the aliens were flying the [ __ ]
planes into the towers my mom was out
predicting memes she knew she's like i'm
gonna [ __ ] my kids for life right into
tower seven baby towers having
productions dude that's our new
production company jeff and karen
oh is this mcgregor's tweets but dude
mcgregor does do that it's like yeah
he's like back up karen it's almost like
you want like you got a homeless guy
coming out on the street i don't want to
risk you know catching any like blood
blood to blood contact so let me just
do the push kick and it's very much like
you don't want these hands so i'm going
to let you know that by just i'm going
to put this so you know what and if you
keep coming then it's gonna be these and
feel like uh like this in mma is a good
technique to start out the fight like
push them away but also if you try that
out on the street you might hit nuts and
you might hit [ __ ] and that's there's
no timeouts on the street so that's an
effective way
to get to not engage in and to throw a
shot but also like say like look you
don't [ __ ] want it they might get hit
in the nuts you could take off you know
before the cops get there like look i'm
still going to dinner with my wife yeah
yeah exactly we're going to be at no
yeah you might have some dress shoes on
or something yeah
[Music]
i wonder if you suck if you saw him in
person you ever met connor in person no
me neither but i wonder if you saw him
in person if he looks because some
fighters if they had on a hoodie yeah
you may have no idea if it weren't for
the ears you know yeah
um
yeah what happened with connor connor
and uh cormier got into it yeah uh
connors
took umbrage with some criticism that
daniel corbyn made on one of his mma
shows and he just started going off on
daniel cormier daniel corman is a fat
mess
getting into worse condition by the day
god bless i mean he's retired you know
showing up drunk at media events the
very day before he was in the booth
calling my fight oh he so he was upset
at bias commentating
so he was imagine if he had that [ __ ]
baseball commentator on his fight yeah
he probably would have loved doing the
irish accent yeah i can't help but do
the irish accent and i don't know if
that's you know that's a great point if
that would have been an irish guy i bet
there's no problem because i [ __ ]
[ __ ] love it yeah it's just [ __ ]
to be honest i don't give a [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you mister it's a hard accent to do but
it's just so fun if i was commentating
the fights if i was daniel cormier i'd
be cancelled big time because i would
just do the whole fight in an irish
accent but i i don't think you'd get in
trouble for irish accent would you think
you'd get in trouble i mean if conor's
just pissed about
him gaining weight
on his own in his in his own life in his
own time i think he's just going to be
pissed about everything that cormier
does and cor look let's be honest dude
cormier is that thicky you know what i'm
saying he's built like uh like winnie
the pooh
went to freaking crossfit for two years
yeah you know he's got that he has the
body style you're talking that babe ruth
body style where it's just he got all
the body you got every part
and you're still great at whatever your
sport is yeah and and that's a perfect
example because it's mma where you have
to you know make weight but he's a
heavyweight so yeah you could be 265 you
get up there but now you got guys like
inganu that are now using every
like
cubic square of [ __ ] muscle on your
body has to be like lean muscle you know
and gone was a [ __ ] specimen man that
guy is terrifying you see the picture of
him next to the the smallest heavyweight
champ like the the heavyweight champ
next to the lightweight flyweight straw
weight
i don't know all the weights there's too
many i'm like a
mine would be just wait dude i need a
few minutes before i go in the ring
that's my weight look at this
oh my god that's that brian moreno
brandon yeah brandon moreno wow the
lightest ufc champion and the heaviest
oh my god and the crazy part is ngano
seems like the nicest guy in the world
yeah french yeah jackson
the french are coming up bro that's
cyril gagne
nganu yeah that's gonna be a good fight
who'da thought
um
let's go back what did cormier respond
nick
he said
i bet you and god will run right through
that wall
we can't no problem
oh yeah
two reps
he'll hit it and then go again yeah he
might just punch through it i went to
the ufc pi in vegas and they have that
thing where you you punch and it tells
you like how much your velocity is or
whatever the [ __ ] yeah and i hit that
[ __ ] as hard as i could and i couldn't
even get a third of what ingano got
really yeah and i had a shot i was there
with a pro fighter and he got less than
i did and ngano was punching
you know three times harder than that
what the [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] insane were you with sugar
shawn
no i i just [ __ ] pulled in i said i
was with the elk boys oh yeah i wasn't i
wasn't with anybody i was just like i
was just [ __ ] i respect that yeah
i snuck in i infiltrated the ufc pi
no i had a friend there that was
training but that it would have been
cooler if i just left it the other story
yeah i lied i'm i'm an elk boy i like
that dude
i think uh
i don't even know if i know the note i
mean i know who the nuk boys are but i
don't know if i know any of them in
person yeah oh steve i met
yeah i feel like you get along with them
i met some of them
and they're hustling yeah they're doing
their thing oh yeah they're kind of like
in the same world do you ever feel like
the same world that you guys are yeah
100 yeah that's so cool that so many
people kind of cross over each other and
do stuff together
yeah
good guys
um
[Music]
i got they they make some edgy jokes
they got me in trouble one time they
sent me a package of merch
and one of their shirts had epstein on
it
and
my friend one of my friends he looks
like a young epstein he's like a little
rat looking face
and i always call him epstein so i made
a joke as a i was promoting their merch
because they sent me a nice big box and
then i was getting canceled just for
promoting their merch
so i mean it's just what you give a [ __ ]
to is there value in getting canceled
these days like my friend morgan wallin
he has like he got cancer or whatever
and he's like the biggest musician in
the world the n-word situation yeah yeah
um
i mean he's a big now he's i think he's
the biggest i mean he's basically like
the
okay he's like the male katy perry now
yeah oh yeah i mean you're saying that
he'll be on tour for 10 years if he
wants to i think anyway
so that actually helped his career it
definitely didn't hurt him i think the
way that they beat the media beat him
down about it it just helped him it's
almost like if you want to sell a good
tour
get cancelled first not that morgan
couldn't have without it but i
apologized or did he just yeah he kind
of did no he did a little bit of like
the song and dance you know that they
make you do yeah for sure well he grew
up in the south yeah where you know did
he get a pass from somebody
because i don't know if i don't i know
that doesn't count but no but it kind of
i mean look he called it like uh
he called his friend his white friend a
[ __ ] ass n word yeah you know yeah and
he didn't say er he said a yeah which
you can buy in music so to me i to me
and a lot of my black friends didn't
even think it was a big deal yeah you
know it's really just the media but if
you can get the media to bite into yeah
something controversial i wonder do you
think it can help your vibe these days
yeah yeah
i mean if if if that's part of your
brand and you just double down on it and
you don't apologize you just say this is
who i am and i made a mistake times are
changing you know i don't know this is
[ __ ] i probably shouldn't comment on
on this stuff oh i don't know i think
it's interesting yeah um
but i just feel like is cancel culture
now something people can use as leverage
to be a better
to promote it's almost like like six
nine did if you watch that documentary
about six nine
his whole thing was like six nine is a
documentary bro and it's multiple yeah
and it's fascinating bro his whole thing
was to me
i'm gonna tell these rappers rappers are
not tough anymore mm-hmm the guys who
were shooting each other they both shot
each other biggie shot tupac tupac shot
biggie yeah they shoot at the same time
how'd that even happen
and here's what it was like a month
apart or something right oh one of them
must have shot straight up in the air
then dude
crazy bro but here's the thing he
realized you're like none of these dudes
all of them are just about like internet
cloud anymore there's no real killers
yeah i'm gonna call all of them [ __ ]
yeah and that's what he started doing
and he's right none of them are going to
kill they all just want to have their
it's more dangerous to be a youtuber
because now you'll be like called out to
box and okay now you got to actually
fight you know
so you got to be more hardcore to be a
[ __ ] youtuber now than a rapper i was
talking about bro that's so true
i was so talking to yogati the other day
and he was like what's the deal with all
these uh youtubers boxing and money in
that and i was like well back in the day
when rappers had beef they would just
shoot each other now
like youtubers in our world they found a
way to
resolve that conflict and also monetize
it
and
you know like some people get in the box
and they love it like the paul brothers
they actually
live and breathe boxing now yeah move
their trainers into their houses like
they are putting millions into their
training camps and
they're
you know they have resources that are
better than most fighters have you know
a lot of a lot of these fighters are
getting paid two grand a fight if that
you know how do you pay for training
they're like grateful just to get in the
gym yeah
yeah i think it's just fascinating yeah
why aren't these rappers like if they
have any real beef it's like the rappers
have turned into
the actors yeah and the youtubers are
the [ __ ] ones that are actually about
it let's settle the beef yeah look at us
we're in combat sports training what
then what the [ __ ] yeah what are we
preparing for
i don't know i would be willing to fight
someone in a couple of years oh yeah i
think
somebody like around
i think if brendan shaw lost he's a you
know british i'll do it and i do a show
called king and the sting and he
formerly did ufc
but if you he's a heavyweight though you
can go after him i'd have to gain 40
you'd have to lose 40.
oh so he would be [ __ ]
a toothpick and you would bulk up like
cormier probably yeah
i don't know i'd probably go after
somebody with a little less experience
because he actually has octagon
experience yeah you're right maybe bobby
lee he wrestled in high school he'd
probably leave a perfect match up it'd
be good [ __ ] talk back and forth on
stage you know press conference you get
up there you [ __ ] do the accent like
that you get canceled your career blows
up
and then you [ __ ]
beat his ass yeah dude
beat him up actually i could beat him up
i think i'd hate to didn't he say uh
some martial arts experience or is that
just me he does but i bet it's deep into
his bone marrow now i mean it is he's
put uh he's more and it's embedded in
his brain it's his instinct now it's
actually more dangerous at its
instinctual because he could just you
know rekindle that
that's a good point
and his body's parts aren't far apart
so i feel like he can like manage his
body
you know like some remote controls like
the original playstation controller like
there was just a couple buttons and it
was close and easy and then you got that
xbox thing you're like
yes i think i have too many
whereas he's just like you know yeah
it's more straight punches down the
middle that's all you need one too yeah
that's all you need to know
a lot of people don't know bobby
wrestled uh at poway
where's it at poway high school
uh this guy has a question about
employment for each one of you is this
dopa's yola it looks like it but i don't
think it is
what's up brad king
jeff how we doing it's your boy meter
from jersey um
theo's a big dp fan uh that's poirier
not the other thing and jeff likes
connor i mean would you guys ever you
know get in the ring fight [ __ ]
ratting me right out over here i mean
i think uh
i think theo would uh sleep jeff in like
30 seconds don't drive us against each
other bro we just met we're [ __ ]
finally warming up to each other and you
want to drive us against each other and
he [ __ ] ratted me out and being a
connor fan yeah
you know i look
i don't like conor's actions recently
colin cormier fat [ __ ] is kind of a
little funny yeah you know like yeah
he's he's got to
work on his respect levels right now but
also he's going through some serious
[ __ ] he's got a life-changing injury
right now when i was when i smashed my
[ __ ] head off the crane i was saying
all types of bat [ __ ] crazy stuff i
still am today i probably said things on
the podcast
you know yeah well at least you could
use a crane andrea if anybody was like
why did he say that be like just show a
picture of a freaking big john deere you
know what i'm saying yeah
yeah you're done you could say whatever
you want yeah you're mentally
handicapped blame it on the crane dude
blame it on the crane uh i made a song
about it too you did yeah at the end of
the documentary you'll see it so yeah i
skydive into a musical performance at
the end i couldn't figure out how to end
it i was like this is some sad [ __ ] it
got real dark and then i just wanted to
end it on a happy note so i covered
higher from creed ooh
yeah i was [ __ ] jumped out of the ai
jumped out of a hot air balloon and then
i just started singing and it was like
like because i can't sing i'm not a
musician but i could do like funny
singing voices yeah
so i did that and then i reached out to
him and he like gave me the rights to to
do it or whatever really yeah that's
awesome have you ever done uh the one
that josh adam myers does at the comedy
at the uh
jam jam uh
he has comedians and entertainers come
on stage and sing with a live band like
you you you god damn comedy jam goddamn
comedy oh damn i don't i don't know if i
could do that i could do it for like if
i sold tickets my own tour i could do it
for my own fans but going out there for
people that don't know me and then i
just started doing a shitty cover of
creed i did it it was bad everybody did
it like open mics i don't know where
does that route no no it's not an open
mic it's like a real show so they've
just the crowd is there just they know
it's comedians and entertainers or uh
comedians performing
music that are not singers so they know
but it's a real band and it's like a
good people are just having fun but
people like the average person has way
more musical talent than i do really
yeah i don't have any i i have like
like bad music what skills do you think
you actually have like what are some of
your honestly what are your skills
fighting i could probably [ __ ]
take off the average youtuber's head in
a boxing match you know um have you
thought about challenging anybody
yeah i've been doing it on my own
podcast people are sick of it there i
just call somebody out every week and
nobody's taking the bait right now what
about ethan klein
oh yeah that but i mean he wouldn't take
the bait i mean what's in it for him
money yeah you know how much money can
you possibly give him he's not gonna do
it he wouldn't do it i would love that
match up because he's [ __ ]
you know said some things about me but
it you know he's a heavyweight he would
probably like to do a debate like a
mental battle what about trisha pattaya
i mean that's man a woman that'd be a
new thing you'd have to get trained i
thought she
not sure you would have to get a whole
new league of like uh who's even down to
put that on that bare knuckle they put
on [ __ ] triller would probably put it on
filler would hit they don't give a [ __ ]
bro triller is basically like any time
i've ever been in a huge nightclub in
jacksonville and had to go find the
bathroom yeah that is what i feel like
i'm wandering through when i watch
trailer somebody's singing over here in
this corner it's very poorly lit i
wouldn't there's a fries
a rematch with the crocodile on that
girl they might try to they might try to
set that up and just promote it the
rematch of the crocodile versus the mma
girl
dude that's where we're headed it's
definitely getting interesting it's like
we're all heading into this space where
it's like
there's just the
things are just publicized fights now
the ufc is like the biggest sport in
america yeah
i realize it's my favorite sport same
it's it's great football used to be my
favorite sport [ __ ] that lynn running
around with helmets on and gear throwing
a ball around yeah just put two men in
only one can win yeah you know you have
to make that man [ __ ] either quit or
go to sleep go unconscious you know
what better what's better than that do
you think you could have done it looking
back on your life if you'd gotten into
it early and really trained do you think
you'd had a chance in it um do you have
that thing
i don't know i don't know uh
i mean i got in plenty of fights growing
up but i've lost some you know
that might have [ __ ] up my momentum
you know if i had a loss like who'd you
lose you do you remember
i mean i've had group fights where i
just got clipped from the side and stuff
like that yeah i remember i lost uh
this one fight or fought some guy on
steroids he was on performance-enhancing
drugs we i wouldn't test him or anything
after that he
walked around school saying i'm off the
wheat i'm on the juice oh yeah he's a
real juice head and yeah just [ __ ] i
was out of my weight class so i have
weight classes you know i tried to go
after a [ __ ] big dog i got [ __ ]
pummeled yeah
i thought it was a humbling experience
you know i wouldn't change a thing
except maybe the [ __ ] you know the
crane i lost the fight to the crane yeah
but even that i got tko'd i didn't even
get knocked out that's awesome that was
a 2k there's a doctor stoppage actually
that one was a doctor
with the crane
the [ __ ] crane dude we should do a
fight review sometime i wonder if that
would be cool or not you and me
commentating i think i think we just
came up with a goddamn
you know and get a fighter too we have
to get somebody who fights who knows
what they're talking about do we
i think we know enough
i don't think we do
we could just do [ __ ] accents like
that guy yeah and you know oh coming to
the plate
we'll get views
we'll lose all our sponsors i'm sure
liquid death will stick around but well
they're in it for the long haul dude
going to jail
that was your conor mcgregor if
anybody's wondering yeah that was my
connor man oh yeah
oh i'm gonna fight you bubbe
they're all bad man wow i mean i get a
lot of practice all i do on my podcast
is talk about myself and do conor
mcgregor impressions people are pissed
but i'm warming up to it
yeah i'm getting used to it i got a
sound board and stuff so i got i got the
20 year olds i believe in aliens flying
planes and they're just hitting buttons
all day
and it throws off any form of
conversation that gets started oh yeah
but i think that's like what i'm used to
because i'm in the younger generation
where everything's just quicker and we
cut ours those edits it's not like rogan
where it's just they sit down and have a
conversation and they could just talk
for three hours yeah
it's hard to be on joe rogan do you
have a catheter tube hooked up to your
penis i'm gonna do those because i gotta
piss right now and i feel like we've
been going only for like a half hour
yeah two and a half two hours i had to
pee so bad
i remember some of my all my thoughts
started to have like it was on an ocean
do you get nervous to tell him like can
i take a piss break yeah yeah because i
got a little of that right now yeah i
don't want to interrupt the show but i
gotta piss back yeah go peeing we'll
come answer this question from this
young lady okay yeah we'll come right
back for this damn i was holding that in
you were you weren't pissed off that i
have to go piss not a chance man no i'm
glad you're getting it out of you
attention listeners
across the galaxy from
minneapolis to mozambique
from atlanta
to
florida do you have a problem with body
hair
has your body hair going to the next
level
is your
huge pubis hair growing into your
mustache or your belly
does your armpit hair run all the way
down to your balls
well
get ready for an out of this world
experience when you try the new
performance package 4.0 from manscaped
it's popular in the usa canada
and across all the other countries
inside this package you'll find the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
the lawnmower 4.0
has a 4000k led spotlight you can turn
on and off when needed for a more
precise shave throughout your travels
across the universe
that's right get twenty percent often
free shipping
by going to manscape.com theo
that's twenty percent often free
shipping by going to manscape.com theo
help preserve our podcast
and
take care of your
pubis hair
that's right
manscaped you know hair is it's tough to
come by different hair you might have
hair you might not somebody you see
somebody with a mustache you want to cut
it off them
and put it on your damn scalp you want
to take care of yourself
you want to take care of your hair more
than 50 million men in the u.s
suffer from male pattern baldness
yep
there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
keeps
offers them both
yep keeps has more five star reviews
than any of its competitors low-cost
treatment start at just 10 dollars per
month and keeps offers generic versions
as well
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months to see results but
you will
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash theo to receive your first
month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash t-h-e-o
to get your first month free keeps.com
theo thank you for supporting the
podcast
i'm refreshed
nice
hi jeff hi theo my question for you jeff
is did you really lose your virginity at
age 12
and if you could go back and change
things do you think you would still lose
your virginity at age 12
um love you theo
love you so much jeff
gang gang snip snip
so if somebody's been neutered
if i could go back and change anything
i'll go back to when i recorded that
video and said that it was 12 because i
think it was like 14 or 15. yeah i think
i exaggerated a little bit when i said
that but
she did some deep diving research for
that and so i love you back and i
appreciate you for watching all my stuff
way back then when i said that in a
video because i was new to youtube i was
just blurting [ __ ] out yeah it's been
[ __ ] 12 or whatever i didn't know i
was going to stick and resonate with
people i might change
how this girl lives her life well what
if she lost her virginity at a young age
because you did because i did so what if
some 12 year old watches that and you're
like you know what i'm going to go
outside right now and bang somebody i
know i know so yeah if i could change
anything i would go back to when i said
that because that was a lie and i'm
spreading misinformation
i must have been 14 15 which is still
early but yeah but in new jersey is that
early i feel our new york is i feel like
that's freaking after that movie kids i
feel like it's like anybody so you gotta
hump by the time you hit a hit about
eighth grade yeah no i had already been
in and out of gangs multiple gangs
different [ __ ] yeah
yeah so i grew up different but i don't
i don't
suggest it i don't recommend you do the
same thing i did but you know i don't
regret it whatever there's a little gang
life i think that lady looks like she
could use definitely would you want a
gang something light nothing heavy you
know maybe a book club that also buys
knives or something mm-hmm you know she
might ever be part of one yeah she's
watching both of us i think yeah yeah
she's not doing yet she's definitely
doing great
it's funny to see the crossover people
that watch the both of us because i saw
you posted a picture on instagram saying
that i was coming on
and like the picture you picked of me
was it that was the old version of me i
had no mullet you know i wasn't my true
form at that point
and there were people on there like who
the [ __ ] is this guy like [ __ ] this who
is this somebody wrote me who's this
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it's pretty cool
i thought god damn
yeah that is pretty cool
yeah all right well i guess you have
some messages but yeah i saw like like
people comment and stuff like that they
were pissed off so it's interesting to
see like these videos it's nice that we
do have
crossover fan bases yeah her
that's
it and anybody yeah anybody who likes
getting their haircut uniquely yeah
which i think is so many people now have
mullets man i know it's kind of a little
frustrating because we had we had our
thing you know me you and kenny powers
and now it's kenny really he launched it
years ago but it didn't really pick up
it was almost just like a look at the
past kind of because he i think was a
character from the past you know yeah
it's kind of like he plays a an
exaggerated version of himself i i just
before i finish i don't want to leave
out roof raft because i know that's a
buddy of yours yeah i've spoken to him
too about doing stuff together uh like
shooting a
uh podcast or something together and i
know he's a an avid mullet
representation
he's an average he's a piece of hit him
riffraff should be in a museum yeah some
people are like a segment of time
trapped in a person
and riffraff is like 19
for me
and this is judgment
he's like
19 8 like 9 89 to like 94.
oh damn
89. really wow yeah yeah he's you i feel
like both you guys have that in you
you're both
unique in your own ways oh yeah similar
extremely unique man
because i went everyone to his place man
i went to his place in florida and he
took me like immediately like dirt bike
riding in his neighborhood and quading
in his neighborhood and it's not like a
neighborhood aquatic in so the neighbors
are all like oh you know yeah they're
all like taking their trash out but
that's the only time that dirt biking or
quad is fun when it's on the streets
illegally yeah and if somebody's
flipping you off while you do it yeah
yeah and you're gonna go to a dirt track
and do it the right way you got to load
it on the truck and get it off and all
that [ __ ] and your mom's there
when you get a track yeah sign off this
[ __ ] [ __ ] it just ride it down the
street
join a gang
yeah new york and the dirt bikers in new
york like meek mill and like over there
on the east coast oh yeah we would just
ride the dirt bikes in the street it's
way more fun the cops come to chase you
just skid go the other way that's
legendary i went to jail for that too
you did yeah one time but i feel like a
lot of things it seemed like you would
get stopped for was there an act did you
rebel against police and that also
helped you get to jail i wonder was
there an extra element yeah yeah oh yeah
[ __ ] you yeah that's what i see i see
like okay there's this one introductory
element where about 80 percent of people
may be making out
yeah but whitake is like nah [ __ ] you i
got myself in a deeper hole
i'm like that kid in the breakfast club
where he's like he's like you got
detention and i'm like [ __ ] you and he's
like say something again and he's like
he just keeps saying it that's me i keep
getting time added on
yeah dude yeah you basically stopped by
a police officer to ask for directions
and next thing you know you're in
freaking solitary confinement for a year
what the [ __ ] did i do
yeah
um that's a good question that lady had
man
i remember being young and having sex
man and that was the best time to be
sober enough sober sexist for children
i've always said that
and i believe i was 17 man
but when you're when and once you hit
like 12th you're just trying to find
somebody who will let you put your penis
in them i feel like you just want to get
it done so you could tell your friends
that you did it yeah and tell yourself
you can do it uh-huh
yeah because you're this you're this
weird thing that wants to have sex and
that hasn't done your base it's like the
legend of zelda kinda
now see i don't even know what zelda is
but i i can kind of understand yeah it's
like final fantasy or some game you know
it's like i gotta get to the end i gotta
defeat the boss you know yeah the vulva
or whatever i just pissed off half your
audience there not knowing what zelda is
no they don't have them i just wasn't
into games the only video games i played
was grand theft auto just go beat
somebody up if you don't feel like
playing the game
that wasn't grand theft auto dude that
was your 20s okay
look at the miami drinking days vice
city too it is very blended that time
reality and me playing that game in my
childhood i might be mixing some [ __ ] up
that's probably why i said i was 12 when
i [ __ ] lost my virginity of course
you did i was thinking about the game oh
you're throwing somebody out of a cab
bro yeah i was a little prostitute and
grand theft auto
yeah yeah you do have kind of like a uh
like a grand theft auto kind of history
i feel like i live my life like grand
theft auto yeah still to this day even
my place that i live in my apartment
it's designed like the mission
like room everything i i do i go out i
do a heist i bring it back there
we sort out all the goods
you know it's just that's my mission
room you have one of those big bank
vault wheels on the front of your
refrigerator on the fridge
it's like pretty much sneak up on this
snack pretty much um
yeah do you remember losing your
virginity man was it a scary time was it
a good time yeah for me it was a it was
a scary time i was in the backyard of my
friend tom's house we used to hang out
over at tom's house in his basement
that's where all the whatever we could
get into any trouble you know tom's
parents didn't really give a [ __ ] he had
like a
we all live in duplexes and my my house
was not a duplex but pretty much
90 of houses in staten island or duplex
maybe even a
a triplex or something yeah families all
living in the same you could smell the
neighbors cooking when it comes to the
event yeah yeah we used to have that we
lived in a fourplex oh yeah warplex and
our neighbors made liver all the time
and we would all win it when the liver
smoke would come through the vents bro
we would lose it as kids we would go
hide like it was literally like this
weird game of hide-and-go-seek that
happened i forgot about that
second the liver smoke it would
literally the smoke of it would come
through the vents i just got so lost in
that i forgot we were even talking about
i went back to thinking about riff
raff's hairline oh yeah i just would
love to fix it just line it up yeah he
pushes it back too much
he's got his boy maserati matt i think
who cuts him up man oh yeah i don't want
to disrespect him i was writing that i
take it back his hairline's perfect
i don't want to get barber beef you know
no no
uh
and was it a scary time what happened
was he was a
you met you knew the girl oh yeah so
tom's parents would be up on the third
floor and we would have the basement
down so now we're down like four levels
we're underground we could do whatever
we want down there
beautiful finally we get some
girls over to tom's basement and then
that's finally when i was able to close
the deal now we're both girls that night
was it a plan like we're all going i had
to go out in the backyard because
the basement down there there was always
people hanging out it wasn't it was like
this room pretty much you know so we
couldn't get anything done in there we
went out in the backyard
on a beach towel oh yeah this is where i
lost my virginity it was the first time
yeah i hope my [ __ ] mother doesn't
watch this one she knows she knows in
her heart that's two things that i said
she knows the way that you came home
after that and complained about the
sandwich that you were that she made for
you she came back with an attitude yeah
yeah hey mom make me a sandwich
i got a [ __ ] beach towel on my back
yeah damn
i have four months like have you been to
jones beach is that you guys jones yeah
i went to jones beach as a kid oh that's
cool i caught a fish there i caught a
striped bass off the beach wow
yeah maybe that's what i need as you
know we were talking about the reset
button earlier maybe it's just a good
fishing trip with your old man you know
just go out on a boat
or a lake
you know whatever on the ocean or lake
whatever just fishing
yeah i feel like i'm always searching
for a reset do you feel like that yeah
yeah because things are going good for
me right now i am actually resetting
them starting back up the barbershop
show and that was kind of stressful to
kind of reset that because it's
something i'm so
used to i did it for so long and i'm
like i'm proud of those episodes that we
did
and now we got to kind of
start that back up again and do that
character it's kind of a bad [ __ ] crazy
barber was it a real uh was that really
the way it ended with the guy
that was kind of like a
metaphor yeah it was like me letting go
of the old me that would burn down his
restaurant if he [ __ ] me over and said
you know you gotta get your [ __ ] out of
my house
which was my house yeah he moved into my
house
then went and had the successful
business i would have [ __ ] burned it
down but because of my love and respect
for his family
and me putting that old version of
myself behind
that was me transitioning in that moment
yeah it's it's very weird that all this
happens on a haircut show
all you have to do is cut the person's
hair and interview them but but haircuts
such a changing of the guard when you go
get a haircut it's such a like no pun
intended yeah
it's such a like how am i gonna leave
here how am i who am i what am i trying
to be when i you know go back into my
life am i just gonna have the same vibe
am i gonna you know going to get a
haircut
making some hair choices there's a real
thing to it you know i want the hair
exactly the same because everything's
going great i don't want to ma i don't
want anything to be adjusted let's get
the same you know
trying to hold on to yeah or i want it
to look a certain way you see guys
sometimes have the same the haircut that
you could tell that they've had since
they was freaking four years old you
know what i'm saying that you're like oh
that guy is he's sticking with what
works that guy's missionary hair yeah
yeah but guys got it easy because you
could always like grow your hair back in
a couple weeks you know when women make
a change it's a big deal you know that's
why they want the guy to comment on it
or you didn't notice anything there's
nothing different about me you know
it's a big deal
you know yeah that is true man and i
think especially as women get older and
stuff want the hair you could you know
the hair always can look nice
yeah and so they get their hair done
but yeah for for a guy when you change
up your hairstyle doesn't happen often
in life unless you're
who's exactly like
shane o'malley is always changing his
hair style up yeah whatever
but sugar shawn there's not much guys
that really do that like maybe lincoln
did a happily he had a mullet at one
point didn't he
no
a blinking had a mullet i think he did
there's a drawing of him i've been to
his home uh his home that he grew up and
there's a drawing of him actually with
longer hair
huh
there you go oh sh that's got to be
doctored
i feel like one of your fans made that
edit
i don't know man that [ __ ] looks pretty
fire this is the [ __ ] theory are you
telling me if that dude read it paige oh
that dude rolls up to president bro
i'm voting that one too the america one
i'm voting
i'm voting legally bro if that dude
rolls up
okay that is doctors
that's shake
yeah this guy had a question about his
hair styling days yeah this guy looks
like the type of guy that would get
nervous going into a barber going into
like a super cuts probably doesn't have
a regular barber that he visits he goes
to new people every time
oh you know yeah do you trust people
that go to a new person every time what
kind of person is that person that just
doesn't give a [ __ ] just lives day to
day
but bro that is like us that's like the
pablo escobar affair because like you
are [ __ ] to go to a different person
every time yeah this so that's what this
kid does do we know that about him yet
we should assume
i'm saying i'm okay to assume that i'm
that person though oh we go to a
different barber every time just
whatever's closest or open or whatever
yeah so you're not from here no no i
would do great clips and sports clips
when i was in minneapolis and it would
always be a new lady whose fingers
smelled like cigarettes and
yeah
man i had like uh
i had this italian guy that
that the barbershop that i went to
growing up um
i can't believe i can't remember the
[ __ ] name right now but this place
was like handed down from generations of
like just just italian sons that would
take over the barbershop so cool
and
yeah i feel like [ __ ] i can't remember
this name
but who knows that might have been in
grand theft auto 2 that i'm just
dreaming this up in
i don't know i don't know man it's crazy
your life is just kind of a merger
between grand theft auto and real life
jeff weddick yeah
we got to the bottom of it this is my
therapy session for the week you know
saved me [ __ ] 80 bucks or whatever
you're like john better help
john wick you're better than john this
episode is better than the movie john
wick
that's crazy didn't he ride a horse and
[ __ ] rob like uh sure he did dude he
he did a robbery while riding a horse
this guy's in a time square this guy's
hey i didn't even watch the movie i just
watched that one scene if you even just
look at the box the picture you get the
whole thing
i feel like
see ya vaughn
and jeff whittick
two delectable specimens
um this one's for jeff
what's the best hairdressing story you
have
gang gang oh amber rose walked into the
barber shop and she was like i want you
to shave
my head and my sister's head and this is
when she was dating kanye west and i was
like
you look like kanye west girlfriend and
she was like
sweetie i am kanye west girl but i was
like all [ __ ] nervous
and
she was
beautiful in person like [ __ ] i was i
was very shy at the time
and i did it i shaved her heads
and i ended up dating her sister for a
while after that i shaved her head
and um yeah she was beautiful too she
wasn't her sister she was just
is cutting a woman hair
maybe
maybe do amber rose jeff wittick maybe
we could find something
this might reveal something from my past
that
you had no idea about maybe i won't even
she almost feels like kathy griffin's
kind of sunny no that's not
that sounded
i guess there's no oh there's me and
pauly d
oh yeah that's those are good stories
too
the situation would come to the barber
shop a lot
yeah because he was uh
you know barber shop is a one-stop shop
you go for a haircut and you go you get
everything you go yeah so here you come
in ram you get your deal you get your
dobber so yeah he would pop in a lot
like sorrentino and he's on the jew i
don't know i'm saying he's on a juice
but i would bet but are a lot of these
guys in new jersey on the juice or
they're just look like this i think it's
i don't know his cheeks look all
inflated i think that's a side effect of
testosterone
yeah i used to do testosterone man and i
loved it and i would get jacked
that's probably why that picture i
thought was you oh yes
dude what about this so always
celebrates five years sobriety man
that's amazing
i was just in i'm sure he's doing
ketamine therapy and stuff like that
though he didn't read the fine print
down there he might be on mushrooms weed
and ketamine therapy yeah yeah that's
true
so there's a lot of people trying to
find different ways to get around it man
yeah like there's a lot of successful
people in hollywood that say they're
sober but i hear rumors that behind the
scenes are not yeah i don't know jared
leto personally i don't want to call
like say that it's him but how's that
guy sober yeah you know he's a rock star
[ __ ] doing performances in front of
millions is he in kings of leon
no i think he's got his own
thing uh 30 seconds to march 30 seconds
that's a good same thing yeah same band
um but yeah he's sober and he did
requiem for a dream he was in fight club
he was the guy that got beat up with the
blonde hair
you know
yeah you'd think you'd have to graham
out after that at some point or bowl up
but who knows
like how do you come up with jokes
i just like to talk i start talking on
stage or i'll think of something from
growing up and i'll start there usually
i think i like a memory from growing up
that usually makes me feel pretty good
and then i'll try and come from there i
don't like telling jokes when i don't
feel like happy though yeah so if i'm in
a bad mood man which i've been in for a
while i don't like telling jokes that
much yeah my whole the whole year of
recovery while my eye was growing back
it was [ __ ] hard to think of jokes
were you agitated a lot yeah and i just
thought i was never i would never have
confidence again
not the confidence part
i i knew that you know eventually i
would stop giving a [ __ ] over time i
would just get used to it but
i just was worried that what people
looking at me and the first thing they
feel is bad for you you know oh yeah how
does that translate as you know how can
i make people happy and let make them
laugh
you know that's going to be tough to
overcome that
but oh that's interesting yeah and then
do you become like a charity case or
anything yeah you become a charity case
like it's like whenever you walk past
somebody and you see like
they're in a wheelchair they have like a
like a fake like prosthetic leg or
something like that like oh it's always
the person you're drawn to naturally you
know just as humans that's what we do
it's a surprise
yeah exactly it's just a shock and then
it's like oh no i'm a comedian and it's
just so hard to get past that [ __ ]
prosthetic leg or something like that
yeah i have to compare people like oh
come over here and see this one-legged
guy who's a great comedian you know
saying people are just like they're
where their brain goes you can be
staring at that leg the whole time yeah
but
i watched uh michael bisping documentary
on how he lost his eye where it was like
battling his eye stuff and he
um was getting surgeries on it and one
of the surgeries got infected and that's
when he eventually like i think he lost
his eye i'm not sure exactly 100 percent
i'm supposed to talk to him soon it
doesn't work well but he still has it in
his head
oh yeah i i i took it out i saw a
thunder he can take it out completely if
you take it out it doesn't really attach
it's not like an iphone charger yeah no
unless this is
oh no he so he lost his eye 100 yeah and
he won the belt with one eye yeah he
beat luke rockhold that's not saying
much you know
he won the belt i didn't here's the
crazy part luke i'm just kidding luke
rockhold if you watch this i don't know
i know you got it luke rockhold's so
good looking dude we can make fun of him
okay yeah that's true that's the only
thing i love you luke but he's gonna be
fine okay
luke rocco dude if he doesn't have a
fight with ufc he's definitely going a
few rounds with somebody's wife
somewhere okay oh yeah luke rockhold is
doing
fine bro
yeah so he beat luke rockhold for the
for the title he won the one eye then he
should be
the super champion yes yeah because
pound-for-pound how much does an highway
if you take that out of the head bro
that's a magical house because think if
khabib or john jones had to wear eye
patches for all those fights
they're not having perfect squeaky clean
records you know i don't give a [ __ ]
this thing might have just because
here's the crazy part i've talked to him
20 times in person and never even
realized i knew he'd had a bad eye but i
didn't i just thought it was just
detached i didn't know that it was
unworking
yeah that it was a fake eye you'd never
know
can you tell with mine
i'm just kidding oh my god oh yeah you
did for a second [ __ ] up especially on
this topic now
let me make an apology video
i was doing a prank on theo there that
was not meant to be disrespectful [ __ ]
man that's racist playing with fire oh
look at your eye you take out i might
run into eye troubles in the future i'm
[ __ ] really playing with fire
making eye jokes like that you wonder
what will come you sometimes i wonder of
all the things being recorded since we
record so much stuff
how easily would be for anything to come
back and haunt you you know somebody
just makes a deep fake on you notice
your life in the future like say
anything happens you're like well you
said this and it's just like
this is just karma like the virginia
they're losing your virginity i don't
even remember that i don't know why it's
not even true
yeah you're right we're [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] we did it to ourselves this
is what we signed up for i know we did
you know it is what it is what did we
sign up for that we wanted people to
know who we were what did we sign up for
that's what i want i think to be
remembered so when we have our great
great grandchildren they could look at
at our old podcast and see when we
talked about [ __ ] uh i don't i don't
know ketamine therapy
but you know what it'll be though it'll
be
it'll be a three-minute best of all the
episodes will be surmounted in a
three-minute best-off clip i mean even
if i go watch muhammad ali sometime i'll
watch a whole fight once in a while yeah
but mostly i just go see
muhammad all these greatest moments
yeah you know and it's six minutes of
great moments but you're a busy guy i'm
sure a lot of people
like you know people are submitting
questions maybe they got time to watch
the
the uh full segment yeah they get do a
deep dive into muhammad ali you know
i don't know where we make the content
so we don't get to consume as much
because we're too busy making it
but i think you got to make time to
consume too just not all the awareness
stuff you know like you got to find your
your places to find your content yeah
and what is it netflix and i don't want
to [ __ ] watch netflix not super often
a lot of it
i don't know hulu's hard to manage i
will say this netflix is the most
manageable with the remote yeah
hulu is hard hulu is like having a
diorama dude and asking it to change i
don't even mess with it anymore it's got
too confusing for me i won't even touch
it
it's just two different interfaces it's
very very strange and spotify is tough
too because i used to watch joe rogan's
podcast on the tv and fall asleep to it
no disrespect is just you know yeah
that's when i have time to watch stuff
oh you assume it's at night and you
can't do that anymore with spotify so i
haven't watched a joe rogan podcast in
[ __ ]
probably a good year
you know yeah when he gets on there with
that spacey brother dude that's when i
would really zone out yeah
yeah yeah tyron woodley or whatever that
guy's name is tyrone woodley
no he's not talking about [ __ ]
space montgomery what's that guy's name
i don't even get that afro
you know i saw a billboard for the tyron
woodley fight and it was only jake on it
it was hilarious it was on sunset
this guy is a ufc champion and you won't
have that's messed up dude unless jake
made that part of his kind it said
showtime in the corner
like how disrespectful can you be you
know oh my god come watch this fight
only one guy he's gonna be fighting
someone else
he's just fighting his own how much
money he's fighting his banking yeah
that's what he's gonna make he's
fighting he's fighting with his
accountant after man that's like my
[ __ ] crane video i put the uncensored
one on patreon like this is like just me
doing something like it's you get to
it's like a pay-per-view yeah totally
just me versus crane and how much did
people pay over all you think well i got
i broke the record on patreon so no
subscriptions yeah for like just a lot
of them came just to see the video and
then left but
now i do like extra podcasts there and
stuff but um for that one forty seven
thousand people signed up and how much
is the patreon it was like five dollars
ten dollars a month wow twenty dollars
if you want to see some nudes slip some
nudes in there really of you but i never
did i never worked up the confidence to
do it i just put that option out and
then i backpedaled quick i was like nah
i can't do this
yeah i don't know if i like my how my
body looks sometimes if i'm with a woman
i'll walk out of the room backwards so
they don't see my butt oh yeah
oh yeah backwards you go wow that's a
different technique
like a crab like or not sideways
no no standing up backwards yeah okay if
i did it like that they would almost
think that's cute i think but the other
way is a little bit weird i walk out
literally like a freaking quiet korean
girl you know yeah i mean just like a
moonwalking korean just
um i forgot what we were [ __ ] talking
about we had one more thing we're gonna
talk about what was it nick uh did you
want to talk about the taliban still
being allowed on twitter yeah oh the
taliban
yeah
yeah i thought we got into the taliban
already no we didn't we kind of talked
about the plane not specifically that
they aren't kicked off twitter other
social medias uh talban uses
sophisticated social media practices
that rarely violate the rules wow
so the taliban is this right nick
they're allowed to stay on twitter
yeah
well you know i'm
not all for censorship yeah i support
free speech the taliban did try to kill
my mom if it or could have been the
alien so you know i'm not a big fan of
the taliban good call
so i mean [ __ ] bantam you know block
them off twitter i think they deserve to
be banned
i i agree um
on tuesday
i did not find a single fact check on
any of their tweets and or any warnings
for false misleading content
and the part that's where that's wicked
about this is that this is just twitter
just saying we
will make money off of anything
we will literally let people put
or does that mean they can put like
beheading videos and stuff up there that
doesn't mean that does it no i think it
said
that would be that would violate their
terms
but trump still blocked off twitter yeah
that that's how this uh article couches
it that
taliban is allowed on where well
ex-president trump is still banned
that's crazy
to me that's crazy i mean it's just
crazy that that you could have
just because or what does the taliban
exactly stand for how does the taliban
make money just robberies i think views
on those beheadings
they're getting adsense
and i can't even get adsense on my
[ __ ] barber videos
god damn i think they sell opium too bro
you got to quit taking off the hair and
just take off the whole head
you're aiming a little high season three
yeah it's all the headings
just only on twitter we're gonna have to
switch platforms
yeah youtube's tough yeah
they were cracking down on me for a bit
were they what were they upset about do
you know just the a lot of blood and
gore
uh with the documentary the whole thing
got age restricted um a lot of my barber
videos got age-restricted just because
edgy jokes and stuff you know
once you start getting a lot of
attention on it and they start like
human reviewing your stuff
then it's like
pretty much anything you do they could
[ __ ] hit you for you know damn
and for a while i was on their good side
every video would go on trending and
then after that i think it did like one
beheading or something and just slipped
in there
and that was it on their bad side and
the age restricted like my
last 20 videos
so it is what it is i go back to selling
weed
yeah
i'd buy i'll probably i wouldn't buy
some anyway because i'm just trying to
get to this four step but i would
probably
as soon as i get through all 12 steps i
might buy some okay yeah maybe it'll
help you uh
when you're not feeling so good write
some jokes if you're not feeling happy
sometimes anything against connect we'll
disconnect at night yeah turn off your
brain
yes turn off hulu turn off [ __ ]
youtube
i got like i got really into ufc like
you did over the past year and even on
even on youtube like all of them
recommended is oh conor mcgregor said
this and they put a thumbnail at him
like and it's just his tweet
you know but i just get like roped into
all those and i'm just watching ufc
drama now yeah
there's some good dramatists out there
though i guess it's like wwe for adults
like if you follow the drama that they
talk [ __ ] on each other outside of the
octagon so good and then you watch the
actual fight
so i hope darren till is okay man i know
he's uh he just posted the other day but
he's been kind of on and off over the
past year
and he's one of the best i feel like at
talking [ __ ] i'm talking [ __ ] huh yeah
yeah so funny he just went across like
four weight classes though now he's in
middleweight
he who knows he's like basically he's
like the whack-a-mole of weights he's
like wait a mole yeah he'll like just
literally pop up like straw weight
middleweight you know female flyweight
that's something that's not easy to do
no it's not i learned the hard way i
told you i got my ass kicked by that
juiced up guy on steroids you don't go
after those guys that are just 40 pounds
heavier up muscle than you if you went
after him now
would you do something different after
watson do you do steroids too even the
playing field yeah yeah [ __ ] it i'll get
on the juice tail pack on 20 pounds
let's both go out at same weight class i
would like to you know if white claw
came out with steroids
yeah
can you give it a brand
that's a good brand or nell
started selling steroids bro
we just did a new drop you got to get it
right now today only
everybody buys it
whoops too late we sold out too late get
it next time maybe next month
[Laughter]
bro fulsome steroids bro can you even
imagine
dude every
[ __ ] kid with a [ __ ] shitty
bicycle would be yoked out of it yeah
they would have to sell those out of
india or something or you'd have to go
dude if somebody here's what we need
somebody to start marketing steroids to
indians
dude how i'd love to see a bunch of
jacked oh you're right there is no
indian ufc fighters really
do we does dan
dan even go out there maybe dana needs
to take a trip out there go look around
maybe he'll find some talent
there's bill there's a billion people
there i think they need start some pizza
shops over there first they need a
little bit of new york new jersey over
there they need some sustenance yeah i'm
not a big fan of indian food
i wouldn't be either
it's hard to fight on indian food i
think if you've had a bunch of indian
food i'm not going into a ring after
that yeah you know yeah i'm a picky
eater i don't really like any other food
but [ __ ] steaks i just eat steaks
three times a day damn really yeah i'm
just trying to bulk up damn you like
jordan peterson dude i'm going after
that guy they kicked my ass when i was
15. [ __ ] yeah i'm trying to get on his
on his weight class i would fight him
i'll track him down i'll try to track
him down yeah i would fight him for you
yeah i don't want to put his name out
here now because we have such die hard
fans they might go attack him yeah this
is between us you know it's between me
and him i don't want to send my fan base
after him like a [ __ ] little youtube
and weasel
nah this is a this ain't no to go order
baby we we serving this beef keeping
this beef in the restaurant we'll talk
about it after all right let's look up
his facebook or something i'm sure he's
on there still i like it
um
yeah jeff weddick man you'll have to cut
my hair sometime please absolutely would
you yeah i would love to that's cool man
thank you bro got the new mobile barber
shop coming along oh god pull it up
right here that would do a van or
something it's an airstream good it's an
old trailer and i pull it with my old
silverado oh it's a janky setup but it's
you know it gets the job done
you heard that song silverado for sale
no it's pretty good i'll look it up it's
really good i don't want to admit how
much i like it but it's good silverado
for sale yeah there it is yeah
well look yeah man save up uh
yeah this is a real janky set up i'm
releasing my own hair products soon oh
look there's my doctor who's the first
comment dr raymond he's the one who did
my brain scan he gave me a bunch of
vitamins for my brain
told me to do hyperbaric chamber a lot
oh damn they got you in the chamber huh
yeah he did the
like the visit he's kind of like a
psychiatrist too so he talked to me
about a lot of stuff with my brain like
what might be causing some depression
stuff and he did it for a social media
collaboration but then i got hit with a
bunch of messages saying oh that guy's a
scammer he's showing you a different
brain scan somebody else's really and
i'm i'm like i guess there's no way for
me to tell i don't have my own brain
scanner
that's true
yeah it's great the people that control
the freaking equipment that's who
controls it all what if they're just
sending out bad brain scans someone told
me the other day they they think that
people testing for covid are putting
covet into people
yeah
that makes sense and that blew my mind
that's a whole nother that's a whole
other episode yeah how did you get to
handle jeff we've had jeff and jimmy on
our show now oh that was easy i just um
i i looked up who had it i tracked him
down and i [ __ ]
made him an offer he can't refuse you
know
how much did you offer him 15. no i
killed him oh he killed them that's what
it means and like you never saw that
dude i'm telling you we never saw the
godfather you know i saw i did see the
godfather yeah that's what making her
offer he can't refuse it oh yeah make
you an offer you can't remember
yeah
yeah no i p you actually guessed it the
first time i gave him two grand you did
yeah
yeah that's fair
you know did you know that uh
marlon brando actually was gay was he
really yeah
i believe that
yeah
turns out that uh he moved out to an
island and had like
i mean i i don't i could be spreading
misinformation now no is this true
yeah it's true some people even say
richard pryor and marlon brando hooked
up oh yeah that's the rumor
there's a long been i think there's a
level of
uh when i got the first thing i think
about it and and for that
to come out about
basically the biggest mob boss in movie
history you know like in history you
know whatever fiction non-fiction it's
all blended together now it's oh it's
all i mean we're all 11 gay at least
yeah yeah yeah i think everybody's a
little gay now um do you think that we
are headed towards
a place where everybody
like i often think with like race right
where some of us are different races or
cultures but eventually in 10 decades or
times of having children
we're going to be um
everything's going to kind of everyone's
going to be based together like the rock
or we're going to be basically hawaiian
yeah everything that's actually what
it's going to be
it's going to be kind of hawaiian or on
a plane to hawaii kind of yeah ethnicity
but do you think that that same like
sexually do you think we're headed there
or do you think it'll always be kind of
predominantly heterosexual with some
um
dif like people that are
you know pan or a or homo
sexual
i think it's just everybody's gonna
blend together you do you think
eventually it'll just be yeah
beige yeah i already feel like this
happened throughout my life and i'm only
[ __ ]
you know i've been around 31 years and
i've seen it happen yeah i feel like
i don't know yeah it's definitely
different it's definitely happening fast
i just wonder if that's i wonder what
nature's plan is
because i can see how we shape things
how the media wants to like make
everything very homogenous or
whatever it is
but i wonder what nature's plan is
sometimes
i don't know i don't think it's up to
nature
i think it's up to elon musk
whatever he wants to do you know the
guy's pulling down planets that are full
of gold
he's going to be the richest man in the
world you know that's this whole spacex
thing he's trying to get the mars to
colonize he wants to get some diamonds
out of some
oh if he pulls the first diamond out of
mars or something then that's a giant
diamond that's checkmate
yeah the richest man in the world by
like not even close
you show up with a
[Laughter]
if i could need to available up in space
we need to get up to space yeah we'll do
it man my team of 20 year olds are
working on getting our getting us up
there we'll do it grand theft astro uh
jeff whittake thanks for coming in and
spending time with me man it's a
pleasure and uh i appreciate your
earnestness man and it's nice to meet
you i'm a fan oh vice versa this is
great i look forward to cutting your
hair one day yeah soon brother yeah
practice on yourself in the meantime
maybe i'll do a little on the sides i
don't want to do too much
you know
no haircuts until okay until i pull up
the van now hold on you got it yeah okay
i'll try my best thanks brother now i'm
just floating on the breeze and i feel
i'm falling like these leaves i must be
[Music]
but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my eye
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
train with a heavy load